es ist die 69 Sitzung der 20 Wahlperiode
Tag 2 der haushaltswoche zum
Bundeshaushalt 2023 und gleich um 9
steht in der Tat der Etat von
Bundeskanzler und Bundeskanzleramt auf
der Agenda da geht es um immerhin auch
3,9 Milliarden Euro aber das sind dann
doch nur ein Prozent des Gesamthaushalts
von 476 Milliarden und deshalb geht es
hier weniger um Zahlen sondern um die
generelle Politik der von Koalition
Kanzler und Kabinett und die nämlich in
knapp 14 Tagen seit genau dann einem
Jahr in Amt bzw in der Verantwortung
sind es lohnt sich also schon mal ein
bisschen zurück zu gucken oder auch nach
vorne und deswegen freue ich mich dass
bei uns sind heute morgen Katja Mast die
erste parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
der SPD-Fraktion schönen guten Morgen
ihnen und Thorsten frei ist bei uns der
das selber am Ende hat in der
Unionsfraktion Frau Master sind alles
andere als normale Zeiten Krieg
Klimakrise Corona ist auch noch nicht
ganz weg
ähm sie werden gleich sagen wir haben
trotzdem eine schon nicht viel erreicht
trotz all dieser schwierigen Zeiten gibt
es aber trotzdem einen Punkt ein Thema
ein Vorhaben von dem sie sagen dass es
leider zu kurz gekommen nicht so
ausgefüllt worden wie wir es uns
vorgestellt haben
naja zuerst mal haben wir vielen Dank
erstmal guten Morgen erstmal haben wir
ja schon sehr viel angepackt in dieser
Koalition und wirklich auch in großen
Reformstau aufgelöst sind schwierigsten
Zeiten das haben sie ja angesprochen uns
geht's um den Zusammenhalt wir haben
über fast toten über ist falsch aber
fast 100 Gesetzesvorhaben auf den Weg
gebracht das ist eine beachtliche
Leistung in dieser Ampelkoalition wo wir
gemeinsam das Land nach vorne bringen
und uns geht's vor allen Dingen auch
darum in schwierigen Zeiten des Land
zusammenzuhalten die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu entlasten aber auch
systematisch in die Energiepreise
einzugreifen und da werden wir diese
Woche auch noch mal den Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung bekommen das hatte
ich ihn quasi ja schon vorab auf dem
silbertablette serviert dass sie sagen
werden wir haben mehr geschafft als als
viele sagen aber gibt es trotzdem Punkt
wo sie sagen schade da hat uns die Krise
gehindert mehr zu tun nein die Krise hat
uns nicht gehindert mehr zu tun sondern
wir haben mehr getan und natürlich haben
wir noch viele Vorhaben vor uns zum
Beispiel die Kindergrundsicherung ein
wichtiges Vorhaben aber das war schon
immer klar dass das erst später kommt
die Stabilisierung der Renten
beispielsweise und vieles weitere aber
wir haben ja tatsächlich gerade in der
Energiepolitik Dinge vorgefunden die
Gasspeicher waren leer als wir die
Regierung übernommen haben es gab keinen
Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien das waren
ja riesenreform Staus und das sind wir
überall dran und auf dem Platz sie haben
vielerlei Sie und Ihre Fraktion auf
jeder der Kritik geübt haben und der
Koalition dass sie legitim und sogar
auch ihre Aufgabe gibt's trotzdem ein
Thema oder ein Feld wo sie sagen so viel
dramatisch besser hätten auch wir das
nicht hingekriegt
also erstens wunder mich wundere ich
mich ein bisschen wenn die Frau Mast von
Reformstau spricht denn die SPD hat ja
nicht die Regierung übernommen sondern
die SPD hat seit vielen vielen Jahren
mitregiert in diesem Land zweiter Punkt
ist der ja man muss glaube ich einfach
anerkennen dass wir in ganz besonderen
Zeiten der multiplen Krisen sind der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
die Auswirkungen auf die Energie
Versorgungssicherheit auch die
Energiepreise das hat ganz starke innen
und wirtschaftspolitische auch
sozialpolitische Implikationen das sind
besondere Herausforderungen aber was ich
kritisieren würde ist dass in einer
solchen Zeit der zeitenwände wie es der
Bundeskanzler formuliert hat eben auch
eine entsprechende Schwerpunktsetzung
Priorisierung da sein muss ich finde
gerade nicht dass man sein Programm
einfach abarbeiten darf als wäre nichts
gewesen und jede Krise dann in
Sondervermögen als Schulden oben drauf
kommen sondern jetzt käme es eigentlich
drauf dann die richtigen Schwerpunkte zu
setzen setzen sie die falschen
Schwerpunkte Frau Mast
heute glaube ich nicht mehr einig ob wir
die richtigen Schwerpunkte setzen
überrascht einmal aber ich will schon
noch mal sagen in welcher Lage des Land
war und warum ich Reformstau und auch
von Vernachlässigung beispielsweise der
Bundeswehrsprecher wir haben
keine Bundeswehr übernommen die
im Verteidigungsfall und dem bundesfall
so ausgerüstet wäre dass wir das können
das hat war viele Jahre in Verantwortung
der Union und deshalb kann ich das auch
hier mit Fug und Recht behaupten und ich
möchte den zweiten Punkt man den nicht
ganz kurz weil ich lasse das so nicht
stehen der zweite Punkt ist dass wir
zwar mit der Union immer auf unser
bestrebenden aus Atomkraft ausgestiegen
sind und auch
kohleausstiegsdatum festgelegt haben
aber wir haben die Union hatte nie die
Kraft mit uns den Weg zu gehen nach
vorne in die Investitionen regenerative
Energien und Alternativen und ich habe
ganz bewusst glasspeicher angesprochen
ein Bundeswirtschaftsminister der
zulässt dass die Gasspeicher bei fast
Null sind wenn er das Ministerium
übergibt da kann man schon von
Reformstaus sprechen sie kommt gleich
daran keine Sorge ich wollte ja trotzdem
den Punkt den sie vorhin gemacht haben
auch an der Stelle nochmal aufnehmen
erhalten Torsten Freiheit ja recht wenn
er sagt sie haben ja mitregiert viele
Jahre in der großen Koalition machen
sich ein bisschen zu einfach zu sein die
sind Schuld also zuerst mal war der
Bundeskanzler oder die Bundeskanzlerin
hatte die cdu-parteifarbe und ich habe
gerade ausschließlich über schwarze
Ressorts gesprochen in der Vergangenheit
und es liegt dann schon auch in der
fachverantwortung der Ministerinnen und
Minister für ihre Ressorts die richtigen
Punkte nach vorne zu bringen aber das
ist Vergangenheit Bewältigung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger heute ist wichtig
wir lassen sie in der Krise nicht allein
niemand wir gehen die Gas und
Strompreises systematisch an und wir
nehmen die Dinge in die Hand wo wir
Deutschland zukunftsfähig nach vorne
entwickeln und deshalb ist so wichtig
eben beides zu tun die Krise mit hohem
Engagement zu managen und die Dinge nach
vorne zu bringen und gleichzeitig die
anderen großen Reformvorhaben auf den
Weg zu bringen wie diese Woche dann auch
das Bürgergeld haben
noch was mit auf dem Weg noch ein Punkt
nämlich die Frage sie haben weil sie die
sondertöpfe erwähnt haben hier auch sehr
kritisiert werden weil sie außerhalb des
regulären Haushalts stattfinden können
wir vielleicht auch noch mal genauer
darauf gucken wie ein System gelöst
diese Krisen und die Kosten die durch
diese Krisen entstanden sind also wir
hätten eine andere Schwerpunktsetzung
vorgenommen an einem Sonntag Vermögen
haben wir übrigens mitgewirkt eben
nämlich dem Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr und es bringt mich zu dem
Punkt den die Frau Mast angesprochen hat
auch ich möchte nicht in die
Vergangenheit schauen und die Frage
stellen wer denn die Beschaffung von
bewaffnungsfähigen Drohnen verhindert
hat wer die Ausfinanzierung von zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
die Bundeswehr verhindert hat sondern
möchte einfach die Frage stellen warum
in dieser Situation
entgegen der Ankündigungen des
Bundeskanzlers der
Verteidigungsetat gegenüber dem Jahr
sogar um etwa 300 Millionen Euro sinken
wird also wenn das alles stimmen würde
was die Frau Mast gerade vorgetragen hat
dann müsste die Bundesregierung und die
sie tragenden Fraktionen doch jetzt
deutlich mehr in diesem Bereich
investieren tun sie aber nicht und um
Ihre Frage zu beantworten am Ende geht
zum Schwerpunktsetzung wir haben die
Situation dass die Bundesregierung in
diesem Jahr etwa 500 Milliarden Euro
neue Kredite aufnimmt das ist so viel
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
den ersten 40 Jahren ihres Bestehens
aufgenommen hat ja aber jetzt sagen Sie
auch das war falsch aber sie sagen nicht
was die Alternative gewesen wäre aus
ihrer Sicht ja wir hätten bestimmt
andere Schwerpunkte aber welche sind das
denn wir hätten also wir hätten
investiert in die Zukunftsfähigkeit des
Standortes wir hätten weniger Kredite
aufgenommen und wir hätten natürlich
auch einige Maßnahmen so nicht gemacht
beispielsweise wenn sie etwas konkret
haben möchten wenn Sie immer an des
neuen euro-ticket Denken des 49
euro-ticket was sicherlich eine gute
Sache ist aber man muss dafür auch das
Geld haben und da hätten wir eher in die
Infrastruktur in die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur in des
schienennetzs in die Bestellung von
Wagenmaterial investiert als in die
Subventionierung von Preisen so viele
Stichworte bekommen auf diese reagieren
kann bitte schön vielen Dank also zuerst
mal
sagen dass unsere Entlastungsmaßnahmen
und
es steht der CDU ja offen die
entsprechenden Änderungsanträge heute zu
machen und das alles dann zur Abstimmung
zu stellen oder bzw am Freitag was sie
ja so nicht tut ähm das ist ja dann auch
schon mal bemerkenswert aber uns geht's
darum dass wir das Land nach vorne
entwickeln wir investieren auch mit
diesem Haushalt so stark wie noch nie
zuvor also das heißt die ganzen
Zukunftsinvestitionen machen wir
zusätzlich zu den Entlastungen und den
vielen Vorhaben die wir haben und gerade
in der Verkehrspolitik finde ich ein
bisschen lächerlich dass mein Kollege
frei
ausgerechnet diesen dieses Beispiel
herbeizitiert weil gerade da haben wir
ein riesen Aufholbedarf beim Ausbau des
öpnvs beim Ausbau
schienengebundene Infrastruktur und so
weiter und deshalb ist das 9 € Ticket
das ja nur drei Monate gehabt dann ist
49 Euro Ticket in Zukunft einfach ein
wichtiges Signal und weil wir
vernachlässigen dabei nicht parallel den
Ausbau der Infrastruktur weil gerade im
ländlichen Raum das ist mir besonders
als Baden-Württembergerin wichtig
brauchen wir auch mehr Angebot für
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr eine
bessere Vertaktung und dazu nehmen wir
auch noch mal zusätzlich Geld in die
Hand weil es ist völlig klar um vom Auto
umzusteigen brauche ich auch das
entsprechende Arbeit
die Lage im in ihrem gemeinsamen
Bundesland natürlich auch ganz gut und
sie noch mal wieder ja also genau das
findet ja nicht statt eine stärkere
Investition in die Infrastruktur die
Regionalisierungsmittel sollen um eine
Milliarde steigen das dürfte aber in
etwa die zusätzlichen Spritkosten
auffressen das wird die Länder nicht in
die Lage versetzen den öffentlichen
Personen Nahverkehr wirklich zu
verbessern und deswegen findet diese
Schwerpunktsetzung eben gerade nicht
statt im übrigen wir haben in diesen
Haushaltsberatungen etwa 370
Änderungsanträge auch Maßgabe Beschlüsse
gestellt wir haben uns also intensiv
eingebracht um genau diese
Schwerpunktsetzung richtig vorzunehmen
und dafür zu sorgen dass die Kredite und
die Schulden nicht weiter durch die
Decke gehen ich will nur einen Punkt
ergänzen es ist ja nicht nur alleinige
Aufgabe des Bundes den öffentlichen
Personennahverkehr auszubauen das ist
mir ganz wichtig und deshalb kann die
Union ja gerne in den Bundesländern wo
sie den Ministerpräsident stellte in
Baden-Württemberg regieren sie mit noch
mal tatkräftig zusätzliche Programme
machen um den öffentlichen
Personennahverkehr auszubauen aber
meiner Kenntnis nach wird es in
Baden-Württemberg zum Beispiel nicht
gemacht wir haben die Krisenzeiten am
Anfang auch schon mal angesprochen ihnen
beiden ist sie sind ohnehin bewusst
irgendwie es wird trotzdem auch viel im
Detail gerungen bei bei einzelnen
Punkten und ich frage mich und es wird
auch teilweise sehr scharf Argumente
argumentiert sie gehen jetzt hier sehr
sachlich miteinander um was sie sehr
angenehm finde und tauschen Argumente
aus bin habe gelegentlich den Eindruck
dass der politische Diskurs dem Ernst
der Lage nicht entspricht würden Sie das
teilen
ich fange mit ihnen an nicht nicht
unbedingt also es ist glaube ich ganz
selbstverständlich dass sie dieses
Gespräch immer ausdrücklich ausgegeben
ja aber wir pflegen das ja auch
ansonsten durchaus im Parlament ich
glaube man muss unterscheiden zum einen
kommt es in der Krise darauf an dass man
auch in den entscheidenden Situationen
zusammensteht das haben wir auch als
Opposition so praktiziert auf der
anderen Seite darf man den
Parlamentarismus in einer solchen
Situation auch nicht ausschalten ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass die
Bürger auch merken dass es in nicht nur
Meinungsaustausch gibt sondern auch ein
Ringen um die besseren Argumente und
deswegen versuchen wir den Finger in die
Wunde zu legen darauf hinzuweisen was
nicht gut läuft und idealerweise
natürlich auch bessere Vorschläge zu
machen und das haben die Menschen dann
zu bewerten was für sie überzeugender
ist
ich glaube dass es die Aufgaben für
DemokratInnen und Demokraten ist in der
schwierigen Situation in der sich unser
Land befindet auf den Zusammenhalt zu
setzen und ich bedauere ausdrücklich
dass gerade bei der Debatte um das
Bürgergeld insbesondere von der Union
ein sehr spalterischer Ton angewandt
worden ist wo man versucht hat
geringverdienerinnen und ringverdiener
gegen diejenigen die nichts haben
auszuspielen bei gleichzeitigem nicht
zustimmen zumindestlohn wo es darum ging
das Leute die wenig verdienen mehr Geld
bekommen und da auch oft nicht mit der
Wahrheit agiert worden ist zum Beispiel
beim Thema Sanktion wird immer
unterstellt das wäre nicht ab dem ersten
Tag möglich gewesen und solche Dinge was
alles nicht stimmt das geht um in neue
Kultur des Förderns und Förderns es geht
um eine großen Auflage Weiterbildung und
es geht darum Menschen gute Arbeit zu
vermitteln also ich könnte es nicht
richtig nachvollziehen auch wenn da
immer wieder von ausspielen
unterschiedlicher Gruppen gesprochen
wird die Sozialdemokratie hat ganz
offensichtlich nicht verstanden dass man
den Euro immer nur einmal ausgeben kann
genau darum geht es letztlich und wir
haben am Ende eine Lösung gefunden die
ja sehr nahe ist an einer Lösung die der
Bundeskanzler Schröder in einer
rot-grünen Regierung einmal gemacht hat
und deswegen wundere ich mich über die
Kritik und die Sprache der SPD doch sehr
jetzt dürfen sie noch mal und da müssen
wir langsam zum Ende kommen nein bei
Bürgergeld
geht es nicht darum was Bundeskanzler
Schröder mit den Grünen übrigens damals
sehr verwässert durch den
Vermittlungsausschuss im Bundesrat durch
die cdu/csu gemacht hat sondern es geht
um einen neuen Aufschlag auf Augenhöhe
es geht um eine bessere Vermittlung in
dauerhafte Arbeit nicht jeder Job ist
okay sondern der der die Leute dauerhaft
aus der Hilfe Bedürftigkeit führt also
das ist entscheidend das ist der große
Aufschlag des Bürgergelds und den lasse
ich mir hier auch nicht glauben
und fördern und das wird jetzt mit
diesem Kompromiss aufrecht erhalten
deswegen ist ein guter Kompromiss wir
werden dieses Thema hier morgen um 8:45
natürlich und im ganzen 15 Minuten
führen weil dann ja auch die
Entscheidung des Vermittlungsausschusses
da ist und man dann auch sagen kann in
welche Richtung ist tatsächlich gehen
wird wir sind ja noch in so einer
Vorstufe Frau Mars vielen Dank dass Sie
heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind auch
ihnen vielen Dank Thorsten Freise wir
müssen jetzt glaube ich relativ fix
reingehen sehe ich auf dem Monitor der
Bundeskanzler spricht jedenfalls in
dieser Sekunde schon mit dem
Oppositionsführer sehe ich da noch auf
den informellen Ring man tauscht sich da
aus und man kann offenbar auch nach wie
vor gut miteinander reden vielen Dank
sie dürfen rein